masqué et confinés dans leur classe
ces élèves vont visiter virtuellement le
musée pointe à callière ça nous sort de
l'ordinaire puis cette année mais il
faut s'accrocher à chaque petite chose
qui sont différentes notre quotidien est
trop pour le même on a l'impression de
vivre le jour de la marmotte cette
rencontre virtuelle vient tout juste
d'être créée par le musée pour combler
le vide laissé par l'annulation des
visites scolaires dans son mini studio
la guide présente les vestiges par
vidéoconférence et bien sûr elle répond
aux questions c'est estimer à combien la
valeur c'est certain qu'avec la pandémie
a fallu vraiment repenser nos
interactions j'ai filmé les petites
capsules vidéo avec un contenu et
socialement quand on aborde des jeunes
en visite en présentiel habituellement
le musée pointe à callière mise beaucoup
sur ce projet de visite guidée virtuelle
parce qu'il est difficile de prévoir le
retour à la normale
là pour nous c'est vraiment une
expérimentation donc là justement ce
moment c'est ce que vous êtes venu voir
on est en phase de rodage donc on essaie
de tester avec des écoles parce que
c'est vraiment un apprentissage des deux
côtés au xiii se serait de rejoindre les
écoles partout dans le monde donc
clairement donc c'est sûr que c'est
l'opportunité que nous propose le web
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de frontières
quand on construit des murs si toujours
le début de la fin également touchés par
l'arrêt des sorties scolaires
la maison théâtre si tous ces mets au
virtuel elle offrira aux écoles des
ateliers donnés via la plateforme zoom
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'à ce
moment-là ça disponible partout à
travers le québec mais aussi si jamais
ils avaient l'option que les élèves ne
peuvent pas retourner en classe et qui
font l'école à la maison on s'arrange
aussi pour donner les ateliers avec une
petite finale de zone déjà plusieurs
écoles ont manifesté leur intérêt pour
ces ateliers
oui on en a quelques dizaines en fait
qui vont qui vont avoir lieu en octobre
novembre déjà si on est prête c'est
savoir la lie
les demandes pour des sentiments
pour éveiller tous nos sens rien bien
sûr ne pourra remplacer une vraie visite
mais pour ces jeunes l'expérience avec
le musée pointe à callière arrive à
point nommé
j'avoue que ça me faisait du changement
qui tout et ça vient ça explique milieu
il ya beaucoup de choses que je n'avais
pas comme malgré le bon choix c'est elle
qui a fait la première école ici ici
louis fait déprimer radio canada
montréal